what's up wordsmiths this video is about
the word eliminate
[Music]
it's a verb it means to remove or get
rid of something
the word comes to us from Latin and it's
a combination of two parts X which means
out or away think exit and limit which
means Edge or threshold think limit
you're pushing something over the
threshold then out the door
there he goes you'll notice it's not X
lemonade sometimes X gets shortened down
to just e
as it does here or in words like eject
or emit for now just know that sometimes
X becomes e as in eliminate
thinking of those elements X or Lim try
to come up with a couple of similar
words in English that contain those
parts I'll give you 10 seconds all right
take it away music break
[Music]
here are some of mine
exit like the opposite of an entrance a
place you go out of limit like the edge
or the end of something and subliminal
this is a fun one it means below the
threshold of awareness you might have
heard of subliminal messaging like how
I've been subtly flashing the words eat
more mangoes on screen for the last five
seconds
I haven't been paid by any mango Growers
or anything I just think they're tasty
fruits but to eliminate something is to
get rid of it
for good
let's try it in a sentence and you can
see how it comes across it usually has a
kind of dire connotation kind of scary
our new directive of public order will
eliminate those troublemakers for good
sneered the minister of peace
right creepy I didn't even need to do
the voice uh getting rid of
troublemakers for good sounds pretty
frightening not gonna lie
a less creepy example you might see it
in an advertising context like this
fabulous product eliminates 99 of
household odors fabulous little product
in its spray can it it removes the odors
it takes them away it puts them beyond
the threshold the limit of your
awareness I hope that this video has
eliminated any confusion about the
meaning of the word eliminate all right
I'm exiting now catch you in the next
one you can learn anything David out